so uh Mike Tyson is considered by many
to be one of the great boxers one of the
greatest boxers of all time heavyweight
boxers uh what do you think on the
positive side made him great I don't
know he was ever
great I know he was
Sensational I know he was the greatest
mix of maybe speed and power
ever I know he was one of the greatest
punchers from either side of the plate
left or right there's been great punches
with just the right hand like Ernie
Shavers and Deontay Wilder and Max bear
I don't know if there's ever been anyone
who could punch as good as he did on
either side with either hand other than
Joe Lewis and a few others I don't know
if there's ever been such a combination
of speed and power to that pure level
that he had and it was a pure level I
don't know if there was ever as good a
fighter as Tyson was where maybe one
night he was great where he wasn't
tested but he might have been ready to
be tested that one night against Michael
Spinx when he took him apart 90 seconds
I think I saw a great fighter that
night I don't think you can be great
unless you have
all the requirements of being great what
does it take to be a great
fighter truly
great to not rely on someone's else's
weakness to be
strong to be strong on your own too
often he relied on other people's
weakness whether it's the by being
intimidated or whether is because his
talent was so much greater than as that
it was like putting a monster truck in
there with a Volkswagen and the
Volkswagen was going to get crushed no
matter how much horse power the folks
wagon might have had under the hood and
you put under the
hood it was going to get crushed the
monster truck was not going to allow it
to be a contest
and to be able to find a way when your
talent wasn't enough he didn't find a
way when his talent wasn't enough and he
and I'm not making statements if I'm not
ready to put some evidence you know like
if we were in a courtroom exhibit a
um when he fought when he fought Buster
Douglas um the Douglas matched his will
and didn't get intimidated stood up to
him he didn't do what most people did he
didn't submit even a little bit not that
night he had in a pass but that night he
didn't why because Buster had buzer had
a secret weapon that night his
mother buz's mother had died a few
months previous he loved his mother very
much bust had always had Talent big
heavyweight talented could punch Tech
technically
solid he was all those things always was
but he quit in fights he he he did less
than he should have done he never lived
up to his ability he gave in he
submitted he wasn't strong enough he
never had a reason to be strong enough
when his mother died he had a reason
nothing could hurt him as much as his
mother dying hurt him Mike Tyson
included that night Mike
Tyson could not hurt him as much as his
mother had hurt him by dying that night
he had a reason to be strong for his
mother and he was strong he was
everything he was supposed to be and
more and he stood up to Mike and Mike
for the first time maybe ever was in a
fight where he had to overcome something
where he had to be more than talented
more than a
puncher more than a guy with
scintillating
speed and he wasn't and then that night
got followed by another Knight with
Holyfield h Holyfield wasn't as talented
as him as big as M
puncha but
Holyfield had the
character he was strong in ways that
Tyson wasn't strong he was strong in a
way
where he could find a way he was willing
to find a way he's willing to go to the
cliff to to truly die before he
submitted you know a lot of stuff is
just wor yeah they're gonna have to
carry me out on the shield yeah sure
sure okay yeah until it comes time to be
carried out on the shield sometimes
there's people that actually mean
it you think Mike didn't have that well
all right he let's just say arbitrarily
I don't have his record for me let's say
he was 55 and five I know he had about
five losses all right let's say he was
55 and five right a lot of
Knockouts I have a saying a fight's not
a fight until there's something to
overcome until then it's just an
athletic uh exhibition contest yeah
who's a better athlete who's got more
quick twitch fers who's who who's more
developed who's in better this who's
who's more developed in those physical
areas but a fight is not a fight until
there's something to overcome
okay so if you go by my definition not
Websters my definition which I think
means
Something Mike Tyson was only in five
fights in his
life the five fights where there was
something to
overcome and he didn't overcome it now I
know people hate me for this including
Tyson I I understand hate me oh you're a
hater because you weren't with him you
didn't make the money because this
because of that because you got
betrayed I think I'm better than that I
hope I'm better better than that I
believe I'm better than that I'm not a
hater i' I've broadcast fights for 25
years on ESPN where there was some
people in the corner I did not like and
if they did a good job this guy's doing
a great
job and then there were guys that I
liked and I had friendship or he he he
he messed up and we weren't friends no
more friendship got to be tested
remember that so we weren't friends no
more but why did I do that because it
was my
job it was more important for
me when when it's all over with the only
thing you're left with
is I mean we're going to be dust all of
us right the only thing we're left with
is what carries on our
reputation you know Legacy whatever that
is but our reputation that's all we're
left with and that's all our kids are
left
with I wanted to be as good as it can be
I've always had a ability I've done a
lot of things wrong and I've had a lot
of
lackings but the one strength I've had
if I had a
strength is to understand
somehow through osmosis I guess to learn
the
lesson that was
important is not what's in front of you
for those 5 seconds for that moment in
life it's what's left behind you when
those 5 seconds are gone when that what
whatever it is that you're dealing with
you know whatever the that moment is
whatever that moment what you do in that
moment the action of that moment is
going to stay with
you and be you it's going to become you
mhm what what you face for that
moment it's
gone it's it's gone in the air in an
instant it's gone it's done whether you
take whether you stand up there and you
get shot in the head and the guy
freaking blows your brains out or you
freaking you you stand up or you're
fighting a guy who's like an un a scary
guy to fight but you fight him and you
beat him or he beats you up
but how
you represented
yourself in that
moment is all that matters that's going
to live what happened don't
matter it don't matter that you guys
shot in the head I know that sounds
absurd but if you believe that it was
important to stand up and had take the
chance to get shot in the freaking head
rather than to live like like an empty
vessel you know
what that's all that freaking matters
and somehow that got freaking wrapped
into this freaking head of mine like
that's what matters that's all that
matters you know how many times I went
and I I the were things whether it was
with this one with Tyson with that I
didn't want to be there I was scared to
death but I was more
scared I was more scared living with
regret how I have felt yeah I don't want
to be in solitary confinement the rest
of my life with that freaking guy in the
cell next to me called regret I don't
freaking want to be next to that guy if
I want to freaking go down that road
I'll watch papon you know what I mean
and and I get my f from that but I don't
want to freaking live it I'm afraid of
what my children would think of me if if
I fail in those
areas why
because that's forever when I'm closing
my eyes for the last time I I don't want
to have that fear I don't want to have
that fear you know whether I'm going
down there or whether I'm going up there
you know I I I laugh because uh I I I
was I was around guys years ago that
used to when we talk about that you know
in just you know and um I would get a
kick out of this this one guy who' been
around the block a few times
um when he say hey Teddy I ain't worried
about that I got friends in both
places that's a good line and I yeah and
I thought it was a I thought it was good
uh listen Mike Tyson you want me to say
he was a great fighter then you want me
to betray what I really you know what I
mean you want me to do that I ain't
doing it for listen I could do it to be
a bigger Teddy Atlas and I know it would
work for me I I know it would be do
great promotional work for me I know it
would it would make me more popular in
certain area I know it I'm not that dumb
not that dumb but I also know what else
it would do to
me and I don't wanted to do that to me I
think he was a great talent I think
maybe the night with Michael Spinx maybe
the M Night with M maybe he could have
been that fighter maybe he could but he
didn't never really get tested but he
might have been ready no matter what I
have to be tested that night that how
good he was that's how for even though
it was a guy who used to be a light
heavyweight I get it but it was still a
guy who beat Larry Holmes who still had
something left uh Michael Spinks so and
a great puncher um and an Olympic gold
medalist but and a special fighter one
of the great light heavyweights of all
time you know what Mike Tyson was he was
a meteor he was a meteor that struck
across and not too many meteors and we
still talk about him mhm and and and
unlike H's comment he came back and and
he he's walking around M and he's he has
become greater after his career more
loved more beloved more Ed and he's been
forgiven he found the Fountain of
forgiveness I don't know I wish I could
find that where he has been forgotten
for all his shortcomings all the things
that he may have done may not have done
we don't know only him and God
know but he's been forgiven of all that
and he's been not only forgiven
he's rised above it and and above that
and been brought above that he's been
brought to the pyramids of
of of the greatest athletes that that in
the world and in every in every way in
every way as a person as a fighter as a
historian yeah as a
figure as a celebrity I mean even a
philosopher everything yeah so I will
take it back all right all you guys out
there you forgive me he's the greatest
of all time if you encapsulate all that
if you encapsulate everything I just
tried to
describe um and explain if you put that
all he's the greatest of all time yeah
he is but he still might be 0 and
five in a record of 55 fights he might
Tedd atlas's
book again I got friends in both places
so it's okay wherever I go I I have
company somebody there will like me
despite me saying this he might be on
fight because of five fights where there
was something to overcome which really
defines a fight he came he he didn't
find a
way